[music]
>> As-salamu alaykum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh.
My name's Ibrahim Gaffri. I am from
England, about 30 km outside of London.
I've been a Muslim for 5 years now,
alhamdulillah, and practicing for 2
years 5.
How I came to Islam, I think is probably
the most relevant thing to talk about.
I came from a Christian background, a
non-practicing Christian background.
I never had much purpose to my life,
so I tended to stray between things to
things.
Looking into things like Buddhism,
looking into things like even joining
the army for a sense of purpose.
And alhamdulillah,
I found Islam through a chain of events
which led me to picking up the Noble
Quran.
So, I had a sales job,
and the first person I met on that sales
job was a Muslim, alhamdulillah.
And that day I forgot my lunch, he gave
me his lunch, he gave me water, he sold
he sold kind of Islam to me by
showing me the sunnah.
He didn't say anything about Islam, he
only told me that he was a Muslim.
And that day we went door-to-door sales,
knock knock knock, no one in.
Then the first person to answer the
door, alhamdulillah, was a Muslim.
So, I got speaking to this Muslim,
and I was welcomed into their house
kindly,
and given food, water, alhamdulillah.
And they showed me and told me about the
Noble Quran. At that time, I was
ignorant, I wasn't willing to accept
anything to do with religion.
However, they told me about a theory,
the New World Order theory,
which I was more willing to look into at
the time. So as I started to look into
that, I started to
feel that there's something behind that
that
I had been quite ignorant to think that
there's nothing after death.
So alhamdulillah I picked up the Quran
because logically looking at the Torah,
the Gospel, it
it didn't appeal to me because I'd
vaguely looked into them before. And
Islam I hadn't looked into.
So I picked up the Quran, alhamdulillah.
And I when I read Al Baqarah,
I knew this was word of God,
alhamdulillah.
So you might ask why I was practicing
say that I was Muslim 5 years but
practicing for 2.
I was given a copy of a Quran which was
a
It wasn't a great translation. It
removed the Sunnah from the Quran and
left me with
99% beautiful Quran and 1% somebody's
own personal opinion, which led me
astray. But alhamdulillah, after 3 of
the 5 years, I picked up the Sahih
International copy and studied that and
then I knew that the Sunnah was the way.
And since then, alhamdulillah, I haven't
turned back.
My occupation at home is I work Well, I
have worked for social services. I've
worked for call centers. But now my
goal, why I'm here today, is inshallah
to become a full-time da'ee
cuz being at home,
you can only dedicate a certain amount
of time and it's not possible to fit in
with a full-time career. So inshallah
after this 6 weeks, I hope to move into
full-time da'ee position.
And I pray to Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
that he guides us all to succeed in
this.
So I hope that summarizes me accurately.
[snorts]
Assalamualaikum wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh.
>> I welcome all of you with the Islamic
greetings as-salamu alaykum
warahmatullah wa barakatuh.
May the peace, mercy, and blessings of
Allah subhana wa ta'ala be upon all of
you.
My name is Farik Zakir Naik.
And I have studied from the Islamic
International School.
And I have completed my A levels
alhamdulillah.
From the same school, Islamic
International School.
And now currently I'm pursuing my
further studies
in Riyadh in Saudi Arabia in one of the
best Islamic universities by the name of
Imam Muhammad bin Saud Islamic
University.
And in this when you start this
university, previously there
there are two years for learning Arabic.
But as I've studied from Islamic
International School,
so my Arabic was very good alhamdulillah
by the grace of Allah subhana wa ta'ala.
So I skipped one year and I did the
final year
of the Arabic course.
And I just completed that and after that
I'm continuing my diploma of one year.
But due to this Dawah training program,
I had to skip the last semester of the
diploma.
Because if you want to achieve
something, you have to sacrifice
something.
So that's the reason I skipped the last
term of the diploma because I found it
this Dawah training program more
important as compared to the diploma.
And inshallah when I return back, I will
inshallah pursue my bachelor's in
sharia. And inshallah I have plans to do
masters and PhD in the same university.
Basically we are three children.
So I have two sisters
and I am the only son and I am the
eldest.
As far as my ambition in life is
concerned, I would like to be a
full-time die.
And the studies that I'm continuing
in Saudi Arabia, I would like to
pursue it further and I would like to
master the language of Arabic in order
to understand the glorious Quran better.
As far as this Dawah training program is
concerned,
I would like to benefit from it
and I would like to complete this entire
course
not to gain the certificate, but in
order to become an effective die.
And all of our goals must
must be first to gain the pleasure of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
And so that Islam spreads.
So I would like to continue this course
and learn the techniques of Dawah of
this Dawah training program so that I
can continue spreading the message of
Islam and so that Islam should enter
every home. Wa akhiro da'wana
alhamdulillah rabbil alamin.
Bismillah ar-Rahman ar-Raheem.
Alhamdulillah rabbil alamin. Was-salatu
was-salam ala Sayyidina Muhammad wa ala
alihi wa sahbihi ajma'in.
Dear respected brothers, assalamualaikum
wa rahmatullahi wa barakatuh.
May peace and blessings of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala be upon all of you.
My name is Koichiro Sugimoto. This is a
Japanese name.
And which means
the cure.
Cure means the obedience or humble.
And Ichiro means the first son. So, this
is I mean this means the obedience or
humble
first son in Japanese. And Sugimoto is a
this a family name.
And this is a cedar tree root.
And I embraced Islam
and reverted to Islam in 1997
by the grace of Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala
in Japan.
And
since then, I have been learning for 18
years in Islam.
And I have been to Malaysia
International Islamic University
to study Islamic education for 3 years.
Alhamdulillah,
recently in 2014,
this also by the guidance of Allah
Subhana Wa Ta'ala,
I came to know Dr. Zakir Naik.
And just I like to I explain the the
story a bit.
While I was working in one of the NGO in
Japan to helping giving helping hands
for the poor people
in Bangladesh. We have a project in
Bangladesh. And I went to the city
called Bogura.
And I stayed there and I switch on the
TV.
And I found the Peace TV.
And I found Dr. Zakir Naik was speaking
on the topic called
the label.
If the label shows your intent, wear it.
So, after listening this,
of course, this first time to watch
Peace TV and his talk.
Uh I realized that
this is something I can learn a lot.
And I start to searching his other talks
in YouTube and other
uh video DVDs.
And I found that there are many topics
on comparative religion.
But particularly what attracts me is a
Buddhism.
Oh,
there is a statement related with
Buddhism
from Islamic perspective.
And I search and I listen
carefully and this is beneficial for the
Japanese people to call to Islam.
So, I started to learn more and finally
I decided to translate his speeches.
And his materials which is written.
And finally, alhamdulillah, after 1 year
and a half
published
as a book titled Introduction to Islam
and Comparative Religion. This is fully
totally in Japanese language.
And it was sold and distributed
publicly internationally, mainly in
Japan, of course.
And alhamdulillah, December 2nd, it
become the ranked number one sales on
the religious book
on the amazon.co.jp.
Alhamdulillah, and then since then
Dr. Zakir Naik,
I have never seen personally.
But suddenly I I got information that he
will be coming to Japan.
It was the first week of this November
of last year.
And that was a so much excitement.
And I could attended his
two lectures.
And I came to know that that there is a
the training program will be held soon.
And subhana subhanallah,
he analyzed
the organization of Islam in Japan.
And he mentioned at the very The day I
met him,
that do you have full-time da'ee in
Japan?
Oh, so I was shocked. I have never
thought in that way.
While we are doing while working in
other place,
and we are doing some partly da'wah, so
that would be
sufficient
where the 99.99%
dominate by non-Muslim.
So,
this is a very
uh the first impression
that he analyzed so quickly the very
root, the important the problem of this
the Islamic activity in Japan. And I
decided to
be a full-time da'ee, and I apply and
accepted alhamdulillah.
And then we are here. So, inshallah,
after this program,
I I will be inshallah full-time da'ee,
inshallah, by the grace of Allah subhana
wa ta'ala. And I hope that we will
communicate with these international
participants from now and then forever,
inshallah.
Jazakallah khairan. Assalamualaikum
warahmatullahi wabarakatuh.
>> [music]
>> Allahu
Allahu
>> [music]
>> Allahu
>> time
time
>> [music]
>> time
time